this DJ was so amazing I've never heard  of her and it felt like when she was  DJing so it was like oh this is a  conversation and in stand up like  there's some Comics that just like they  say their jokes but it's almost like  they don't listen to the crowd reacting  or not and then the crowd kind of tunes  out because he's like spewing things but  you're not listening to us later we saw  her in an art car and her and Diplo  they're killing it and I was drunk and I  tried to bestow a compliment on her when  we were watching her there was like this  really vulnerable moment that she had  where she was like I really liked you  guys and then she goes did you guys like  me and then everybody was yeah she goes  okay I'm just working on my insecurities  so I'm approaching her with that energy  so I go you were exceptional and she  goes yeah yeah  she was brilliant